irwins this is long awaited i'm so
excited to talk to you
how are you guys especially in the 2020
of it all
but you do have some good news ahead you
got a baby on the way
we do oh my goodness it's it's looking
good for 2021
in the erwin family we're we're so
excited baby wildlife warrior is
due soon which is great in the next few
months
and everything everything is is looking
good we're looking forward to a brighter
future ahead we just want everyone to
stay safe
and healthy and we'll be on a win but
we're so happy to be talking to you
oh my gosh you guys know i love you so
much i'm so excited for the new season
of your show
australia zoo is still closed since we
lost
steve this would have to be the biggest
challenge we've faced
how much will we see on the new season
of what you and the zoo went through
because you had to close it for weeks
and weeks because of the pandemic right
yeah it was absolutely crazy it was
definitely
one of the hardest things we've ever had
to endure but
it was something that i think made us
even stronger together
as a family no doubt i mean we were all
kind of
in it together and had to just get
through it as best as we could but
that's
a big part of the show i mean we were
shut for a good almost
80 days with just a food bill alone of
about
80 000 just to feed our beautiful
animals so
getting through it all was incredibly
challenging but
we got through it we're on the other
side of it now and the zoo is just going
from strength to strength and it was
really special we were able to
continue all of our wildlife
conservation work as well and there's
just so many incredibly special moments
in there and i think
more family moments than ever before in
this scene
it's really nice yeah well i have to ask
i would imagine you have to think
i know he's always on your mind but you
that you think of steve at a time like
this when you guys are persevering
and then getting that zoo open again was
he on your mind that day
and through all this yeah i think um i
think if steve had been here we probably
would have had
200 staff that would have gotten 78 days
off
because it took about 200 people
that had to come in to take care of the
animals and the gardens
and then the food team had to come in to
feed
them and it was like we were still open
but we were closed and i thought if
steve was here
he'd be doing about 800 of these jobs
it would have been easier in that regard
but we
miss him and we hope we made him proud
and i just think the fact that we
persevered and got through it and
all of us in the whole world have come
together as one community and
that's what we need to do we need to
stand together and we've done that so
marvelously
that uh we're very blessed to be open i
don't mean to spoil the ending but we
reopen
we're okay you're all alive that's fine
bendy i also saw you guys recreate
this gorgeous photo with your tummy
and chandler giving little baby a kiss
in there that was just like the photo of
when you were doing that for robert why
did you pick
that family photo to recreate while you
were pregnant
it is one of my favorite photos ever
captured of
mum and dad and robert in your beautiful
belly
and dad and i were there kissing mum's
belly and it's it's always been one of
my favorite family pictures
and so when i found out i was pregnant i
was very
patiently waiting until the third
trimester for us to recreate that image
because it made me so happy
and it's just it's so special for for us
getting ready for the next generation of
wildlife warrior but i have to tell you
what nobody knows
is that the original photograph was
completely
impromptu yes so we're all walking
through the zoo
and steve said i don't know how that
it's like
your tummy defies gravity and somebody
had a camera because back then we didn't
have
phones yeah so someone had a camera and
he goes
no look at this it's like it defies
gravity
and so i pull my shirt up to show my
tummy and if you look at my face i'm
like
what what are we doing against my tummy
it wasn't a photo shoot it was just
steve marvelling
at the mirror
for me i was a very large baby
possibly bindi and chandler you guys
you've hit so many big milestones uh the
wedding and now becoming parents for the
first time
did you want to expand the family
right away was it always the plan to
have kids and and to get that part of
your life going quickly
yeah i think for for for me i've i've
i've always been so excited to start a
family and i know you're going to be the
best dad on the planet oh i'm so excited
how lucky are we that we're
young parents they get to raise our
daughter in the middle of australia zoo
and get to experience everything through
her eyes and we're just so excited it
felt like the perfect time
you know we had gotten married we were
working in the zoo and it just felt like
a great time to bring our daughter into
this world do we have any
names picked out for baby girl yet
it is such a tough question yes
we keep saying i think we're gonna have
to meet her first
so many people have asked us what are
you gonna name your daughter and
i just i wanna be able to hold her and
look at her beautiful sweet little face
and then i think we can make it
i agree completely yeah it's it's hard
to do
it's hard to decide and i want it to be
perfect so
we'll meet her and then we'll let you
know that's that's what we did we waited
and
met you guys and figured it out i know
how much you guys love each other
and i can't wait to see how strong you
are on the show
how much is going through all this
changed your relationships with each
other i mean bindi and chandler i don't
know newlyweds who have been through
more than you two have been interesting
it was a surreal experience because the
day we got married was the day australia
zoo
shut temporarily so we got married and
the very next day
we were feeding 1200 animals with no one
visiting
the zoo yeah so it's just it was weird
it felt like the twilight zone
it really did yeah but i think that you
know out of
all of the craziness it has brought us
even closer as a family if that's
possible we live together and we work
together but
this this real challenge of a time in
our lives
it brought us closer because you know
when our doors
shut at australia zoo we didn't know
when or if we would open again and it
was
it was terrifying so trying to band
together as a family and
we all took turns being the strong one
and
it's it's important you know it's
important at times of crisis
to come together and support the ones
that you love terry what is this like
for you
to see i i was looking you know i mean i
just love you guys so much i'm always on
your instagrams and robert posted this
video the other day when he was really
little in scotland
and i was just sort of thinking they are
they're so big your kids are so big now
bindi's becoming a mom what is this like
for you how is it feeling is it
emotional to see them in this full-grown
place in their lives
yeah and it's kind of surreal because
you spend
years and years and years being the
parent and then you let them
fledge and you have to go okay now
i'm just kind of a guide and not the
person who says
brush your teeth eat your vegetables you
know you can do that now
so i'm very proud of both of them to see
robert really flourishing with his
photography
bindi has been very science-minded with
our research work
you know they they both are kind of
their own people
very lucky that bindi met chandler
because he's
perfect so that that was pretty cool
plus chandler doesn't drink so i
have a designated driver for life yes
terry and just you know there's so many
beautiful moments it never stops and i
said that to bindi when
your baby is born you go this is the
coolest thing ever
and then every turn of the clock it just
gets different and more wonderful
so it's really exciting but it is weird
looking up at robert
yes that's weird although it's just so
weird for me because i do that with
everyone so yeah
even small children
i mean i you are just the shining
example of how to be a family
and i see in everything you do we all do
how much
you love each other and also honor steve
in everything
this year will be 15 years since
you lost steve since the world lost him
what do you think he would think about
where you are now
and how much you've overcome oh my
goodness yeah well gee i hope he'd be
proud for sure
and i think yeah we've definitely come a
really really long way and it's it's
incredibly difficult i mean you know
it's it's
really really hard one of those things
where yeah not a single day goes by that
you that you don't just
think about it and wish that he was here
more than absolutely anything and
especially
you know in 2020 with the the challenges
and the milestones that we faced from
you know seeing bindi and chandler
getting married i think for me
personally walking bindi down the aisle
i just felt the whole day like this this
isn't this shouldn't be my
job that was his job and and it was um
very very difficult it was probably the
most emotional day of my life just you
know thinking about him
and how excited he would have been and
then you know getting through that
incredibly challenging time as well
you know i wish he was there for that
and it's it is really really hard but
on the other hand i think that it's so
special that we're in this position that
we're still able to make sure
everything that he worked so hard for
and that he loved more than anything can
continue
and and that's it i mean australia zoo
that was always his biggest goal is that
wildlife conservation would be
you know this this worldwide mission
that he had and i think it's
it's really special that as a family we
get to remember him honor him in
absolutely everything that we do and
make sure that you know that that legacy
never ever dies no matter what and now
with a new little wildlife warrior taken
on the charge
oh he would just be insanely excited i
can't even imagine
yeah he would be he'd be over the moon
yeah he would have been a good
good grandfather i will say one thing
for sure is you would never have to
wonder what he would have
worn during any of the milestones he
would have worn cocky to the wedding
yeah yeah yeah cocky to the everyday
involvement no no so god bless him but
yeah he would be so proud of
you guys and the way you've grown up so
amazing and i do have that competitive
feeling still with steve
we were um more alike than i realized
and
and now i just want things to be bigger
and better and more
awesome and everything he built we're
making sure it stays beautiful
and we're growing everything from our
conservation work to our hospital
our charity work is so important and i i
hope he'd be really proud
all right you guys we cannot wait to
watch the new season we're so excited
for you and everything
by the way robert when are we getting
you on dancing with the stars
i've been asking the same thing yeah i
don't know i'd give it a go
i'd give it you'd be really good yeah i
don't know i've got a good teacher